bonjour toujours au bistrot du théâtre
montigny le bretonneux pour un nouveau
numéro de café politique et je reçois
aujourd'hui jean michel fourgous bonjour
ce n'est une paix à des longs cours on
va évoquer au cours de la prochaine demi
heure avec joue les dossiers qui
concernent saint quentin en yvelines qui
concerne et long cours également on
entendra des habitants de votre ville et
puis votre opposant en conseil municipal
à elancourt michel besson est tout
d'abord saint quentin en yvelines après
les élections en mars dernier vous êtes
devenu le premier adjoint de la
communauté d'agglomération en charge des
questions économiques
la droite majoritaire sur le territoire
c'est inédit il ya donc un match qui
s'est engagé avec montigny le bretonneux
entre vous et michel logis pour
récupérer la présidence
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas devenu
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
écoutez d'abord depuis 42 ans dans cette
intercommunalité y avait pas une
démocratie parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'ils aient pas d'alternance
en 42 ans
pourquoi est ce qu'il peut lui aucune
halte 1 147 avait reçu sept choix des
électeurs aussi mais attendez les
électeurs est ce qu'ils sont et ce
qu'ils sont vraiment bien considéré de
façon neutre dans cette histoire c'est
vrai que c'est préoccupant quand on
arrive on se dit comment une structure
comme ça a pu se maintenir pendant
quarante deux ans en alternance bon
c'est une vraie question qui mérite un
colloque deuxièmement nous écoutez moi
je m'entends très bien avec lui chez
laugier région à priori il ya deux
communes qui ont fait gagner
donc saint quentin s'est continuée
l'encours on attendait par manille mais
bon ça a été
comme ça c'est fait bon après on s'est
réparti les choses vont moins il est
évident qu'il ya de fortes chances qu'on
me renvoie aux législatives
bon c'est pas bon donc je vais pas comme
ça cumulé tous les tous les tous les
postes je pense que michel laugier et
plus
je dirais que c'est plus simple pour lui
et je crois qu on en a parlé le mensuel
aussi quelques uns des centristes qui
permettent aussi de rassurer la gauche
parce qu'il faut réussir à gouverner
même si vous avez la majorité ça reste
assez serré à la communauté
d'agglomération donc il faut quelqu'un
va brasser un petit peu les différentes
tendances
c'était plus facile avec michel logis
est ce que vous avez eu cette réflexion
non non je ne crois pas non mais c'est
lé tout ça vous avez la majorité bon
c'est une majorité des majorités même à
une voix ce n'est pas le cas mais vous
auriez une majorité pam qui éclaire donc
avec mich évolution serait partie des
choses très très simplement et ses mots
dire moi même qui ai fait appel
est ce qu'on veut pour lui comme
président ce qui vous intéresse
peut-être ce que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure ce sont ces l'envergure
nationale politique nationale les
législatives vous y pensez
ce mandat vous a échappé lors des
dernières élections vous étiez opposé à
benoît hamon là les prochaines élections
2017 vous positionnez déjà pour les
prochaines législatives
ben oui c'est moi moi ce qui me fait il
faut être passionné pour pour être
efficace quand il est aussi à avoir une
passion faut avoir clamé
moi j'ai une passion pour l'économie et
la création d'emplois notamment dans les
petites entreprises donc c'est vrai que
je suis content de ce poste d'ailier de
donc du développement économique parce
que c'est je suis à l'aise là dedans
et en plus je me bats au niveau national
aussi pour retrouver des nouvelles
mesures pour attirer les capitaux les
talents pour pour donner envie de créer
son entreprise donc bien sur le web
cette délégation du développement
économique et un mandat national ou en
général on me donne des responsabilités
et génération entreprise cesser tout
donné on vient à l'époque vous étiez
d'accélérer avec regarder avec les sound
quand on a passé l'amendement assurance
vie on a des vaisseaux sanguins venir
c'est le plus gros amendement sur la
5ème république et on a protégé un
million d'emplois avec ça pendant la
crise cet amendement se transfèrent
l'argent qui dort mais vers l'argent de
l'économie réelle va les entreprises à
protéger donc environ un million
d'emplois ça ça c'est satisfaisant
oui c'est sont aujourd'hui c'est quand
même l'enjeu est donc devant moi j'ai de
nouvelles idées dire que je teste aussi
à saint quentin et qui demain peuvent
bien sûr intéressé le national donc ça
ça me passionne mais comme vous parlez
du national un poste de secrétaire
d'état un poste de ministre ça ne va
jamais aussi intéressé ce que vous avez
été sollicité pour ça mais monsieur
chirac avait proposé le ministère de la
politique de la ville
quelques années que je n'ai pas accepté
parce que je venais juste d'avoir des
députés
j'avais une circonscription qui était
pas facile ça me semblait pas très
raisonnable d'aller
bon ça ne s'est pas souple et nicolas
sarkozy pour la présidence de l'ump et
pourquoi pas aussi pour pour 2017
ça fait partie des discussions que vous
auriez pu avoir avec lui
écoutez je ne sais pas je connais bien
de ces gens-là bon on va pas se le
cacher mais je sais qui il m'aime bien
et que au travers des propositions que
je fais il y dix ans ils en prennent un
certain nombre donc mais vous dire que
je cherche un peu ce ministre non j'ai
une vie de famille sympathique
là j'ai trois enfants avec ma femme on
s'entend bien c'est un chien non nous
n'en exclut pas le vôtre d'elancourt ça
me passionne le développement économique
à la caisse qui se passionnent demain de
toute façon c'est d'être le travail et
qu'un groupe de députés qui fait quand
même 130 députés jeunes et un centriste
et s'entendent et donc vous avez autant
de marge de manoeuvre quand vous avez
sentant députés qui vous soutiennent
dans des dents des propositions que
d'être ministre ou là vous êtes
complètement conformité vous êtes hyper
contrôlée non j'aime bien un peu ma
liberté je me sens aussi bien à
l'assemblée que dans un poste de milieu
je peux vous dire que pour l'instant en
tout cas c'est pas c'est pas à l'ordre
du jour et je ne réfléchis même pas là
dessus au même moment à 100 je connais
expression votre parcours politique pour
le comprendre justement vous êtes né en
seine-saint-denis à montreuil familles
modestes vous allez travailler dès l'âge
de 16 ans d'où vous vient cette colère
j'emploie ce mot là contre le socialisme
le communisme
ce sont deux tendances politiques que
vous n'appréciez particulièrement pas
n'avait aucune sympathie pour ni les
socialistes ni les communistes
d'où ça vient cette colère écoutez
j'étais à montreuil dans la chaîne comme
vous dites et donc à montrer que c'est
très communiste donc tous mes copains
étaient commises alors il ment
au fait machin alors et j'étais dans
j'étais socialiste entre guillemets
pendant trois mois j'ai pris ma carte
mais j'étais avec j'allais aux réunions
derrière julien dray qu'un jour à cassis
tessa l'assemblée nationale ça fait rire
tout le monde quand il a dit que j'étais
un ancien socialisme mais c'est vrai
mais en même temps je me sois j'avais un
copain là bas il était ouvrier
c'est un garçon qui travaille dans une
petite pme et dix jours du bien de son
patron je me souviens la structure
socialiste il a vu comment tu peux dire
du bien de ton patron enfin il exploite
c'est un type qui n'a rien à de
toi et je trouvais ça très excessive
quoi et oui normalement le type il avait
tellement remontés maquiller ses gains
engueuler de son patron et son patron
l'a foutu dehors
et là il est revenue elle cette espèce
de cellules et il y va voyez je me sens
mal foutu dehors les sociétés sur dix
battu vous en avez raison c'est un
j'ai trouvé ce j'ai trouvé ça
insoutenable cette technique de
manipulation du vivant de la haine quand
ils y ont vendu de la haine du patron de
l'économie de marché du capitalisme est
en fait ils l'ont mis en échec et lui il
faisait payer le train de vie de sa
famille il avait plus de boulot quoi les
autres s'est dit content parce que là et
en plus il est devenu socialiste
militant vous avez raison
donc ça c'était le point de départ des
génies dans chaque mois le lavage de
cerveau franchement c'est pas le top
mais la france un vrai problème avec ça
il y a qu'en france où vous avez je sais
pas mais le socialisme à la spd en
allemagne
schroeder moi j'adhère à schröder je
prends ma carte
mais ceux-ci français avec l'extrême
gauche etc qui n'importe quoi a pas pipi
ventes de la haine quoi je me souviens
ce slogan que j'ai vue dans ma commune
ou dans la circonscription
c'était c'était le mjs il avait marqué
les riches mais ils ont marqué à eux les
milliards à nous les licenciements mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ces images il ya
3 millions d'entrepreneurs vous croyez
que les mecs quand ils voient ça ils ont
pas envie de partir mais qui gagnent des
milieux familial informations il ya la
communication et il ya la propagande le
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que ce qu'on nous donne parce qu'on y
sert essentiellement la probable c'est
riche triste pour mon pays est la gorge
les jeux le revenu je le redis
aujourd'hui
au niveau de la france et quand
j'entends même notre ami à mon ministre
d'éducation à un moment donné sur les
rythmes scolaires de ce que je connais
un peu mieux plus quand il dit les
bénéfices de cette réforme sont immenses
les bénéfices sentiment fin il ya aucune
étude manière ça c'est de la propagande
ministre l'éducation cher et oui c'est
vrai que ça me met en colère mais bon
cela dit on garde son calme et bon voilà
regardez c'est vraiment parler ses
traits de l'ordre voir mon pays
aujourd'hui gouvernée par des slogans
qu'ils sont c'est pas de l'information
c'est de la propagande et c'est triste
c'est comme monsieur sapin ce sapin misé
finance je les connais ils avaient
marqué 2,6 2,6 de taux de croissance
quantités mises et finançant 93 il a
finit à - 0 9
il a falsifié le comble le taux de
croissance de 3 points et demi c'est le
record sous la vème famille est bon le
remets ministre des finances aujourd'hui
je peux vous dire je regardais pas très
calmes encore gens sont effectivement ma
part je suis un peu oui
le temps de reprendre votre cas on va
marquer une pause et on continue après
cette émission
seconde partie de ce café politique
toujours avec jean michel fourgous le
maire d'elancourt nous allons parler de
votre commune on va commencer par
quelques réactions des habitants je
laisse écouter ce sont 4 8 6 à la
résidence des étudiants
je trouve bon bah j'ai été un peu
étudiante peut-être que c'est pour ça
qu'il n'y a pas pour eux
tout près un endroit où ils puissent se
réunir pour boire fumer entre eux
rigoler dial été annie maintenant par
pratiquement partout à l'école les
tablettes numériques pour les écoles
primaires et puis
par rapport au sport aussi il ya plein
de plein d'activités je suis une
ancienne institutrice et que je sais
qu'il a fait énormément pour les écoles
les tablettes dans les écoles tout ce
qui est moderne il l'a fait je trouve ça
formidable j'aime beaucoup ma ville je
me plais énormément je suis depuis je
suis ici depuis fin 70 et j'aime
beaucoup la ville parce qu'elle est très
fleurie et parce qu'on allait on a la
foi et à côté on a des espaces verts il
faudrait plus
de d'endroits où les jeunes puissent se
retrouver
discuter rigoler s'amuser ensemble l'a
fait plein de choses pour les enfants
par contre à skis a déploré ce qu'il a
retiré les appelle la fête de noël de
l'année dernière les plus sur votre
commune développement du numérique à
l'école notamment
c'est une ville verte une ville fleurie
les moins manque un lieu pour les jeunes
les fêtes de noël aussi les festivités
crée du du lion aussi date assez
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit mais
écoutez on a en même temps est élu
gilles quand même la mieux gérée des
yvelines sur un indicateur important
donc voila vous je fais très attention à
la gestion on a peu de dettes on est
bien géré on est quand même au niveau du
fleurissement on a quand même trois
fleurs ni la seule de sa seat apprécié
mais en fait c'est le lien mais même
entre générations entre jeunes mais mais
on n'est pas parfait je vous avoue que
alors d'abord son image j'aurai des tas
de choses que j'aimerais faire un court
mais le problème c'est que je sais que
les français qu'ils soient n'ont pas une
culture budgétaire ont connu de très
fortes mais moi j'en ai une et il est
pas question
mais sûr que je fasse n'importe quoi ça
va quoi qu'ils ont dit mais sa mission
n'aura pas même temps on dit moi les
enfants c'est pas rien quand même
quand les gens disent que c'est des
résultats scolaires de nos enfants que
je dise moi c'est pas uniquement leur
confort là c'est comme si leurs
résultats scolaires
résultat avec interactif les écoles sont
équipées et classes élémentaires de
l'anglais en visioconférence également
il ya beaucoup d'investissements sur le
numérique à l'école
vous évaluez un peu les résultats et les
points positifs avec des bobines la
culture d'ingénieurs que les licences de
lier qu'on développe avec les robots on
a trois robots c'est comme assez rare en
france dans les robots nao balade now et
qui effectivement leur stimulent leur
leurs intérêts les
et donc des sciences de l'ingénieur ils
en prennent tous cas logique
algorithmique informatique leader j'ai
remarqué que le gouvernement c'est
mignon d'ailleurs à chaque fois reprend
assez écoutés c'est très bien c'est
comme les tenir au départ monsieur
d'ailleurs mon opposant là monsieur
besson était totalement contre le
numérique l'état ni les tablettes et
puis maintenant je vois que le
gouvernement reprend comme le modèle
encore moins à l'écouté très bien mais
ce que veulent évaluer est-ce que c'est
évaluer ce qui est inscrit à des
commissions qui regarde les résultats ce
que les résultats des élèves sont
meilleures on en est pas à faire des
études pour voir si le numérique non
mais vous savez bien là avec vous deux
la mienne plus où vous l'avez tous
équipés de l'est bien voilà non moi je
suis là parce qu'ils sont des
révolutions techniques est ce que quel
est le nom courtois qui est prêt mais
alors je l'enlève sons électroniques
dans sa voiture dans son frigidaire sa
machine aujourd'hui 11é typhon n'est
plus un site web je pense que c'est plus
le débat par contre il faut mettre du
contenu il faut améliorer la formation
des profs
il faut améliorer l'appropriation des
outils numériques parce qu'un enfant qui
s'approprient cette culture numérique il
a un avantage par rapport à celui qui ne
fait pas donc je suis là pour limiter
les inégalités et que tout le monde
s'approprie demain quand vous trouve
quand ils chercheront de travail mais
mes enfants ayant pour toi et ben ils
auront une très bonne culture numérique
rappellent qu'ils ont deux ans dames en
scannant culte le même sens mais une
française en anglais également on leur
donne des cours d'anglais à paris aux
conférences avec des profs des états
unis sera enfin ils sont bien formés les
jeux d'échecs pour développer
l'intelligence logico mathématique
je peux vous dire je d'ailleurs grand
mark rutte même les agences immobilières
venise monsieur fourgous c'est la
première fois qu'on voit que dans une
commune des gens viennent habite une
commune il encourt pour à propos des
écoles qui ont une très bonne réputation
on parle d'école on va parler des
rythmes scolaires ou si vous étiez
contre vous avez mobilisé vous avez
menacé de ne pas appliquer cette réforme
des rythmes scolaires finalement ça
s'est mis en place comme dans la
quasi-totalité des communes de france
pour autant vous avez fait le choix de
ne pas mettre de contenus véritablement
cette garderie pour l'instant est-ce que
ça va évoluer
eh bien écoutez j'ai une réunion bientôt
avec les parents où je vais voir si ces
trente minutes + 15 minutes s'ils
préfèrent 45 minutes s'ils préfèrent le
vendredi après midi
yahia débat alors je vais et je
choisirais la pression et ensuite après
ça va être sur le contenu dans le
contenu
dites vous bien que heil en cours on a
un avantage concurrentiel très fort vous
en doutez sur les contenus on est quand
même la commune de france comme la plus
avancer on est cité en exemple à
shanghai et j'étais à shanghai il ya
quelques mois on est cité en exemple en
russie en suède 1 à singapour en corée
du sud plus les ministres d'autres pays
de l'éducation qui viennent voir un
encours bon je dirais que les contenus
on a déjà commencé donc on est en face
de développer des contenus qui serviront
peut-être d'exemple à d'autres communes
actuellement mais je rédige une étude
sur les tablettes et sur l'effet sur la
pédagogie je pense que vous entendrez
parler dans quelques semaines bon voilà
on donc on étudie moi le premier je m'y
applique à comprendre comment on va
pouvoir introduire donc ce serait pour
cette année sera pour l'année prochaine
pour cette alors le problème c'est que
bien entendu les parents ont pris se
sont réglés avec leur entreprise avec
les associations c'est très dur de
changer une organisation donc ce sera ou
pendant le cours de l'année ou
appartenaient les prochaines traite dans
cette émission jean michel fourgous les
responsables d opposition politique
interpelle aussi les élus de la majorité
on va donc écouter une première question
de michel beso votre opposant socialiste
aujourd'hui des cerises élan courtois
est ce que vous pouvez
aujourd'hui nous indiquer à quel moment
l'école de musique d'elancourt sera
transférée et dans le même temps quand
prendra enfin les travaux sur la maison
de quartier de la joe puisqu'il y a des
vraies difficultés à l'heure actuelle
avec quelques problèmes même de sécurité
pour les usagers
avec la pluie il y a
un vrai danger par rapport à l'eau qui
s'écoule entre la nouvelle façade et
l'ancienne façade de l'école de musique
et de la maison de quartier de la joue
sans l'école de musique monsieur besson
a raison sur une chose c'est que c'est
vrai que il ya eu un moment donné une
entreprise qui était en difficulté et
qui bien sûr imposer un problème et on a
pris un retard de plusieurs mois avec
cette année c'était un vrai problème
mais voilà cela dit donc on renforce ce
ça mais c'est reparti les travaux sont
en partie mais c'est vrai que c'est plus
long c'est trop long d'ailleurs c'est
très coûteux parce que le show dyens
essais représentent un coût très
important mais on la bichonne ses sept
écoles de musique et il ya encore de
toute façon l'hypothèse de 2 s'il le
faut de passer au centre oecuménique à
part que le centre oecuménique
bien sûr c'est très coûteux de le
restaurer en ce moment alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya un problème budgétaire youth
prennent d'entreprise mais on ne lâche
pas l'école de musique je rappelle qu'on
donne je crois 160000 euros quasiment
par an oui pour une association
je pense qu'ils ne viennent pas du sud
du soutien de la mairie est l'un des
dossiers les plus importants sur votre
commune c'est la piste de ski ce fameux
skis d'hommes qui fait beaucoup parler
depuis plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
et là aussi monsieur besson à une
question pour vous vous avez juste avant
l'été engagé une première phase de
concertation sur l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt pouvez-vous indiquer
aux téléspectateurs à l'ensemble des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
et d'abord ceux d'elancourt ce que vous
comptez réellement faire nous attendions
une deuxième phase de concertation vous
avait annulé pour ma part je trouve que
ce projet tel que vous l'envisagez me
paraît totalement démesurée et pas du
tout compatible avec l'intérêt des élans
courtois
combien cela va coûter en investissement
pour la collectivité publique pour
l'aménagement des routes des parkings
puis soyons sérieux tout le monde
connaît la colline est-ce que vous avez
réellement fait l'étude nécessaire pour
savoir ce qu'il y avait en dessous et ce
qui était réellement polluer étude qui
devrait être fait par un organisme
indépendant
merci de renseigner les élans courtois
qui sont vraiment très très intéressés
par leur environnement les plusieurs
choses sur l'étude déjà sur la colline
est ce que tout a été menée déjà sur ce
qui compose cette colline qui a été
composé des gravats de la ville nouvelle
à l'époque a alors monsieur besson
donc il est socialiste
ce projet a été lancé par l'ex majorité
socialiste de la casse qui je crois
qu'il est presque une quinzaine d'études
qui ont été réalisés ces pots de
vérifier la caisse qui auprès des
techniciens
je pense qu'il le sait qu'on me pose
cette question bon alors après on entend
plein de bêtises alors vous avez le
militant ou alors le nid temps n'est pas
au stade de l'information et de la
communication m c'est de la propagande
vous voyez un gars de guyancourt
écologistes bon je vois pas très bien ce
qu'il a à voir et qu'ils encourent
l'habitat est en cours il vient créé les
amis de 2 2 même si ça fait partie de 51
ans ce garçon on le voit jamais la barre
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc là il
arrive avec amon machin il sait les amis
de monsieur lannoy qui qui qui sont
surtout derrière cette muse amis de la
colline de la branche à part ça ça donne
même plus là connu la revanche il
devrait permettre aux non au courant du
rosé d'hôtel collecter l'eau qui s'est
monté les amis dans leur signature ya
même des gens de colombie qui ont signé
sa pétition bon non mais très bien le
futur est toute fière que la colombie se
se passionne pour la ville d'el hank au
csu à 30 mètres mais c'est souvent
sérieux alors ces gens là ils vous
disent quoi ils vous disent d'abord que
on va réchauffer la planète va falloir
réfrigérée s'éteindre à réchauffer je
crois que c'est j'espère que c'est pas
bien si je crois que ces deux cents à
peu près de 100 kilowatts
c'est sa part en part m² je rentre je ne
dis pas de bêtises
en fait c'est à peu près ce que consomme
une piscine c'est même un peu moins que
ce que piscine ce que ce que consomme
une patinoire
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc alors
vous allez à la fois vous allez fermer
toutes les patinoires toutes les
piscines et qu'il faut faire mais thales
ont fermé au-delà de l'impact sur
l'environnement j'ai tout à l'heure ça
va c'est et combien ses mains ça va
coûter sur quelle star de man c'est pas
ça le met sur économique
l'investissement après on vous dit c'est
les locaux qui vont payer c'est deuxième
deuxième mensonge
justement pourquoi on va sur ce projet
parce que c'est un privé qui investit 50
millions en ce moment un sinon les
investisseurs partout réalisés ils vont
se concentrer sur leur site après
faudrait genre d aménager c'est ce qui
nous permet nous à partir du moment où
il ya une structure comme ça un projet
qui prend alors il dit ils disent que ce
projet de la colline delà de la piste
prendrait 80% de la colline quasiment
c'est totalement faux ça prend 20 % 20 %
et est même si vous regardez la piste de
ski se disant le frigidaire comme ils
disent ça prend exactement 22 mille
mètres carrés c'est à dire deux hectares
1,2 alors deux hectares 2 sur 52 ha ça
fait moins de 5%
franchement c'est un peu fort de café de
laisser entendre que ça prend 80 % alors
que la piste autour de la piste fric
vous avez un hôtel vous avez un spa vous
avez reste encore donc s'approche pour
seront ni 20% et le reste vous permet
pour les 91 % enfin de permettre aux
élans courtois de se réapproprier cette
colline il ya moins d'un pour cent des
élans courtois qui utilisent qui
profitent de cette colline bien sûr que
c'est là qu'est ce qui qui qui va payer
mais la caisse qui de toute façon aurait
payé n'importe quel aménagement médard a
de risques derrière ce projet de retail
pistes de ski est ce que ça peut pas
échouer tout simplement les parcs
d'attraction des difficultés on peut
penser
eurodisney quai dans un disneyland et
dans un autre registre sur marne la
vallée qui ne va pas forcément très bien
il ya eu des précédents il ya eu un snow
l'oci qui a été créée du côté à
d'amnéville et qu'ils n'iraient pas
forcément très très bien sur le plan
financier non plus vous avez pris en
compte toutes ces données mais le risque
le risque et privés quand on raconte
odile en courtes ou ailleurs c'est un
manque de respect je trouve que la
classe politique doit respecter ses
électeurs on peut pas raconter n'importe
quoi de dire que ces élans courtois qui
m'ont payé mais il ya aucun élément pour
seul indice reste
au fait la planète c'est pareil le fait
de dire qu'il y aura quelques ratures un
même 5 500 milles mais ils ont quasiment
dit qu'il y aura des millions de
personnes à l encours avec ça mais ils
font croire aux gens quand même donc le
même temps il y aurait 500 milles vous
renouez avec une fraîcheur il ya aucun
élément pour dire ça il ya aucun élément
pour dire ça de toute façon dans les
accords avec eux jurent qu'il ya des
règles de deux ans car en cas d'échec à
des liens directs qui sont fixés dans ce
type de contrat je joue pas très bien un
problème je n'aime pas que les gens
s'expriment en terme de propagande on
n'est pas en ex urss en france a priori
encore on est encore en démocratie il
n'est pas normal et vous d'ailleurs
faites votre travail j'en ai remis en
question mais sur dix ont pris contact
avec tout le monde mais il ya une cause
mais quand des gens vous raconte que ça
va réchauffer la planète que sont ces
cours qui va me payer que que safran 80%
de l'aide du site
c'est vrai que c'est pas normal que
qu'on laisse penser à un anneau
elancourt thouaré et à saint quentin ce
projet étape du projet maintenant il est
pas il est ouvert à la discussion
justement je vous invite est ce que
monsieur b / être heureuse et jean
michel fourgous on vous invite sur notre
plateau pour en débattre et pourrait
rencontrer les opposants et vous pourrez
apporter tous les éclairages nécessaires
sur cette question vous serez le
bienvenu fera volontiers le 12 novembre
réunion publique en tout cas sur cette
question à elancourt il nous reste très
peu de temps gm a tout de même vous
faire écouter cette dernière question
qui concerne le périmètre de
l'agglomération de saint quentin à
l'avenir pour ce qui concerne le
périmètre de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
je vais pour une fois à peu près
d'accord avec vous le projet présenté
par le préfet de région n'est pas
acceptable mais il y a des propositions
qui peuvent être entendus par tous et
qui peuvent obtenir un consensus
et pour ma part je pense qu'il doit être
élargie vers palaiseau et vous de votre
côté qu'est ce que vous voulez proposer
aux élans courtois ce soit une
agglomération qui prennent en compte
l'enseignement la recherche est ce que
vous allez vous orienter vers un
consensus qui pourrait réunir l'ensemble
des politiques qui sont en gestion de ce
territoire et ne pas faire tout
simplement de la politique politicienne
parce que ce sont d'autres qui proposent
donc vous êtes forcément contre qu'est
ce que vous dites aux élans courtoise
sur ce sujet il nous reste très peu de
temps en une minute pour conclure les
frontières de l'agglomération à la
d'abord passer de cette commune chiffre
7 à 57 comme l'état nous propose il en
est hors de question c'est pas sérieux
c'est espèce de logique de l'état d'un
autre temps non il faut il faut être
humain il faut il faut respecter le
rythme le riz comme dédé de rassembler
des structures moi je me bats à saint
quentin pour un projet pour faire une
silicon valley à la française
rassemblant la recherche
monsieur b soul igné très bien bien sûr
l'enseignement où je pas trop mal passé
et puis vraiment faire un développement
économique de haute valeur ajoutée ou
vous diriez tous les métiers sur la
chaîne hier sur la géographie mais de
passer à 12 communes de cette commune
est douce commune vous connaissez le
projet sur les douze communes et de
faire vraiment un incident exception
d'exception de pratiquer des meilleures
pratiques entrepreneuriales créatrice
d'emplois de haute valeur ajoutée voilà
c'est le projet 50 ans on a les moyens
bien sûr il faut de l'ambition il faut
il faut on a déjà réuni d'ailleurs c'est
un quentin cc c'est quand même pas mal
vous avez eu des belles boîtes kidiaba
c'est plus les faire travailler entre
elles mieux trouver des financements
pour ceux qui en manquent
ça c'est facile à dire qu'à faire je
vous le dis et puis trouver les
formations les millions et les
conditions de vie pour les pour pour les
salariés voilà deux c'est un grand
projet mais je vous avoue que ça cesse
quelque chose qui me passionne et je
remercie d'ailleurs reçu avec michel
logique dans la répartition vois ce que
je peux vous dire donc content mais hier
plaisir les clès et les communes que
vous l'avez qu'on pourrait associer sur
cette future agglomération de votre
vision c'est un bon pour l'avenir
merci jean michel fourgous c'est la fin
de ce café politique prochain numéro le
16 novembre et je recevrai françois de
ligne et le maire socialiste de
guyancourt
art